a la crisis interna por la reforma
judicial Israel ahora suma Una
inesperada grieta internacional con su
máximo Aliado Estados Unidos en una
declaración inusual el presidente Joe
biden se mostró muy preocupado por los
proyectos de ley de la coalición de
Benjamín neta ñahu al que instó
abandonar la reforma porque si no Israel
se dirigirá en sus palabras hacia un
camino muy peligroso también contrario a
los reportado por el diario de New York
Times en biden negó que vaya a invitar a
netaniazco a la casa blanca al menos en
un corto plazo Aunque Washington ya
había dejado entrever su malestar con la
reforma de estas críticas tan directas
de biden han generado sorpresa en el
gobierno israelí rápidamente netanyahu
respondió que más allá de la gran
relación con Estados Unidos y con biden
Israel toma sus decisiones por la
voluntad de su pueblo y no por presiones
externas incluso de sus mejores amigos
luego en un foro sobre democracia
organizado por el Departamento de estado
el Primer Ministro calificó la alianza
con Estados Unidos de inquebrantable y
se mostró confiado en conseguir una
reforma por consenso menos cálida se
fueron las reacciones de los comentarios
del partido de netanyahu del dicut que
consideraron lo dicho por biden una
injerencia o del ministro de seguridad
nacional itamar venga y vivir quien
remarcó que Israel es soberano y no una
estrella más de la bandera
estadounidense con Washington opositores
y manifestantes mirando de reojo el
llamado al diálogo de netaniagu el
presidente Isaac gersoc continúa su
Ronda de reuniones con los partidos
políticos en busca de una propuesta
consensuada de reforma una iniciativa
que no ha logrado Apagar del todo las
protestas que aunque mucho menos
numerosas se dan seguido registrando
ante la VIP y otras ciudades